salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziare la come al
solito vorrei consigliare un canale e
canale 10
the signor marco carola
blocchiamo il signor marco
monsignor a. che fa
percorsi fra virgolette per quanto
persol youtube si possono fare corsi di
regia appunto di regia
re
dubay spiega diciamo a grandi linee le
cose principali per seguire le linee
il principale da seguire
per fare regia lo fa con uno stile molto
personale e soprattutto molto molto
simpatico
quindi io vi metto il link e nelle
informazioni archivio iscrivetevi
perchè ne vale la pena
anche tu anche se volete abbordare mio
speciale di halloween e nel secondo
canale
metto lo metto come video risposta a
questo qui quindi se volete cliccate
arrivato direttamente lì
detto questo
iniziamo la nuova recensione
e devo dire che questo film mi ha fatto
veramente incazzare è un film
the last time
il film in questione
monster mangio tutta l'arte del ben più
famoso cover film mi assumo a gradini
della trama
un mostro invade tokyo
due ragazze guarda caso americane hanno
firmato il tutto
dici che sono molto difficile riuscire a
recensirlo perchè
paolo schifo tremendo
ma fa schifo piccole dosi che cavolo
vuol dire fa schifo a piccole dosi
numero 5
bastardi
sapete cosa cavolo hanno combinato qui
giri della sailboat su internet hanno
detto che sarebbe uscito questo film
rover freelander nelle sale americane
allora cosa valuta la brillante idea di
fare
noi leggiamo tutte le informazioni
possibili su questo film e prima che
esca
e ci facciamo february
i ludi sentiamo 3 giorni prima di cover
feed così tutti i cannot rupert ed ha
copiato monster ma brutti psicopatici ma
ti pare ma come fa come avete potuto qui
sai che sarebbe potuto funzionare una
porcata del genere ma non ha funzionato
per due motivi principali
il film fa schifo everyday the fatto
malissimo 2 dolores
nessuna vostro film non sei infatti uno
dei più sconosciuti della salma come ho
detto prima una bastardata ma uscita
malissimo
numero quattro
1 danno monica
io odio mettere questi punti nelle
recensioni perchè sono troppo poco
interessanti
mail libero
mi spiegate come fa un film con gusto
che distrugge tutto per caso essere
noioso non ho non come fai a essere
noioso mi correggo
come il phantom a renderlo noioso
hermoso khz
farai un posto che attacca nascita
scommetto che se lo fai d
4 morlupo 4 mori 2-1 per niente e allora
com'è possibile che questo scempio sia
anche noioso better che le per la
maggior parte del tempo si vedono queste
due ragazze che parlano parlano parlano
parlano parlano parlano
canguro parlano parlano piangono parlano
chiaro moka calcolo parcella dettagliata
maltempo si chiama poster dove porca
miseria esto mostrerà tutti siamo utili
per chi si è già rotto le palle 20
volte che si fa toccare con dire che si
è rotto le palle due volte al minuto
numero 3
la trama
c'ho messo un bel punto interrogativo
dopo trama
perchè non sono riuscito a capirla
io l' non voglio un metro paragone con
coverfix perché non mi sembra giusto
in copertina puntata del figliuol di
farmacia cioè spiego meglio
un motivo per cui nonostante ci sia un
mostro che attacca la città
i protagonisti continuo a filmare
soprattutto al non scappare dalla città
improve file per quanto stupido forse
c'era
loro vanno a cercare la ragazza di uno
dei protagonisti la prendo e poi
scappano culi non sono riuscito ad
afferrarla la trama come ho detto prima
ci sono loro che camminano per il tuo
occhio nonostante non lo sanno circa
metà film
scoprono che sei un mostro che distrugge
tutto
perché cacchio non se ne vanno che a
milano a casa e si ritrova dentro te
concato della città dove guarda caso
spesso
il mostro attacca ma senza un filo
logico anche se ad un certo punto non ho
cercato all'ambasciata americana
penultimo che mi è sfuggito ci
tecnicamente non lo vogliono aggiungere
l'ambasciata americana per poi scappare
da tokyo
ora parte l' elenco delle cose che le
protagoniste avrebbero potuto fare per
scappare finalmente invece di andare all
ambasciata americana mappa città
distrutta ruba una macchina sign in
giappone è il più di biciclette rubo
la bicicletta scappo correndo piedi da
qualsiasi altra parte che non si è
certo tipo che dove c'è gusto che sta
attaccando tutto primi incontri e
tagliati le vene
tutto questo per dire che le scenette
subito perchè le persone correlate
quali anche col bastone
sto con i miei che sono appoggiati una
sopra l'altra in una maniera pietosa un
ringraziamento speciale agli
sceneggiatori di fine della sai neanche
riesco a dare sempre il peggio di loro
stessi
2 1 2
scenette quasi a caso ecco quindi siamo
già a parlare un po' più della
computer grafica del mostro
come spiegartelo questo avete presente
quando avete un vecchietto speciale
preimpostate già fatto e dovete cercare
di mischiarlo al film e' molto difficile
infatti non ce la fa nessuno di solito
sibili mischiare un effetto speciale
film
giri tutti i tuoi file effetto speciale
sopra
il film
ma questa è la samuel umberto
esempio quando un posto sta uscendo dal
terreno ci sono le crepe per terra
oppure quando il vostro
con i tentacoli perché dovrebbe su una
piovra gigante ma non si fa
colite katakolon distrugge tutto
&amp fa volare le automobili think love
feel the present succedevano queste cose
c'era il cameraman che stava riprendendo
una cosa
poi certo punto si girava e nella stessa
vi presento rimettevano gli effetti
speciali veniva una cosa quasi
realistica non lo spegnere pc dopo
le riprese si vedono
cose a caso tipo soldati o le due
ragazzi dipende poi
stacco milano
sparco degli effetti speciali staccoli
roma ripresa di nuovo sulle persone a
caso questo
sempre sempre sempre
contatti questi effetti speciali
appaiano 4 5 volte in un film di un'ora
e mezza loro devono farsi tristar culi
effetto speciale sta cu niru ripreso di
quello che si riprendano prima questo
metodo è una tecnica molto precisa
usata solo da registi all'avanguardia
zincata anche sui manuali di cinema a
chiamata grandissima puttanata
numero 1
monsieur
e con questa posizione cerchio di
racchiudere tutto il putridume che ho
lasciato il mio alle spalle con le reply
me 4 posizioni
io voglio vedere il vostro voglio
vederlo
voglio vederlo distruggere tutto voglio
vedere uccidere persone voglio vedere
lanciare concetti aguzzo voglio vedere
palo crollare palazzi
non perchè sono sangue ma perchè ex
guardo un film con un posto
teoricamente posso dire fantastico coppa
atac
altra domanda per voi
secondo voi se loro non riesco a fare la
crepa nel terreno la macchina che viene
lanciata in contemporanea con le altre
yep scene che stanno girando
il cazzo di moto come la fanno vedere
esatto non l'ho fatto vedere o meglio al
usato questo giochetto delle
disintegrare
il nastro la pellicola lalli digitale
quel che la telecamera ogni volta che
tempo da moto marilyn che coincidenza
fortuita così lo spettatore non so mai
acquistato dal parlare
incessante delle due protagoniste
ma non può neanche godersi un po' di
computer grafica squallida perchè non
te la fanno vedere ma porca eva con lo
sto guardando non si vede una cippa mi
spiegate come cazzo faccio a recensione
film e se non si vede nulla ma poi
skoda astrostar memory card non so con
quale telecamera abbiamo girato
ma quante volte si può ordinare
mature in quanti modi si può rovinare
perchè ogni volta che si mi rilasso
rovinato i rovinato in 14 mia moglie si
una volta si vede la pellicola che va
sui giuri quindi pensi che una pellicola
una volta si vede di pixel che scuotono
15 digitale mai visitato con il nastro
housing lido di merda ma poi vogliamo
parlare del finale preferirei di no ma
comunque parliamo di finale in una scena
completamente a caso uguale a tutte le
altre
una delle protagoniste delle
completamente esibire schiacciato da un
pentacolo gigante e li capisci aw che
siamo vicini alla fine del film e
ringraziando il cielo ma cosa succede
sacco nero ovviamente
ripresa
cortili camera totalmente disintegrata
per amica
chi è sopravvissuta con un po di sangue
faccio una ferita al fianco
non sono sicuro che
tentacoli di 40mila tonnellate chi cade
addosso
se il feto soltanto a fianco un po di
sangue in testa
ma come se non bastasse
confsal succedendo la telecamera cosa
succede
secondo me quello finale ligure un
effetto speciale
e' proprio la telecamera che dopo
essersi rotta i [ __ ] di questo film
e serie auto distrutta vi giuro
purtroppo questo film ho guardato da
solo altrimenti ci saremmo annoiati in
due
perchè non è divertente da guardare
con gli amici
non è divertente da guardare da solo
non è abbastanza squallido 2 days e
divertente
trucchi per
orribile che non dovrebbe mai essere
visto da nessuno io mi segnala un sito a
guardare questo film perché io questo
genere di film
lo adoro i film in prima persona dave
kelbrick 2 cooper fibre
ebay buys fronte per quanto fosse una
cagata ep cannibal holocaust baci a
tutti quelli giapponesi per decesso
tantissimi sconosciuti a me piacciono
quindi
questa cosa l'ho presa molto cuore
unlock oddio la sai qualcosa di più di
quanto lo desideri ma esi gia prima
esterna col mio odio verso la file met
urlando alla telecamera ora come diavolo
fanno
arrabbiare ancora di più con loro
esatto